in this video i'm going to attempt to
give you an intuition be behind why
multiplying binomials involve
combinatorics why we actually have the
binomial coefficients in there at all
so let me and i'm going to do multiple
colors the colors will actually be
non-arbitrary this time i'll actually
just to give you intuition so let's
multiply a plus b to the third power
well a plus b to the third power that's
a plus b let me see a plus
b
times and i'm gonna keep switching
colors you're gonna have to bear with me
but it should hopefully be fruitful
times a plus
b
times let me pick an appropriately
different color maybe a blue
times
a
plus
b
right and let's use the distributive
property this equals
a
times
go back in green
a plus
b what's a different green well let me
make sure i use the the right green just
because i the colors matter this time a
plus b
i know this is tedious but it's worth it
plus
b
times
a plus
b
and then all of that
all of that
times a plus b again
right and let's multiply this inside
part so that's and i'm not even gonna
i'm just gonna keep it multiplied out so
it's going to be
a
a
times
green a right we know they're all the
same a
plus
let me just do plus
i should do the pluses in a neutral
color but it's okay
plus
a
times you might be finding this tedious
but it's going to pay off in the end
a times
b
and then we have plus
b
times
a
plus
yellow b
yellow b times
green b
and then all of that we're almost there
we're almost there
all of that
times a plus b
and so essentially we're going to
distribute we're going to multiply a
times everything this blue a times all
of this and then plus this blue b times
all this so let's multiply the blue a
times all of this so the first term will
be yellow a green a and then blue a
so it'll be a
a
a
notice it's different blue but i think
you get the point
plus
this times blue a so yellow a
a
green b
b
and then blue a
a
plus
yellow b
b
green a
a
blue a
a hopefully i'm not confusing you ba baa
we're almost there plus yellow b
yellow b
times green b
times blue a so we did all the blue a's
finally
times the blue a
plus
plus now we're going to do all the blue
we're going to do the blue b times
everything
so it's yellow a
yellow a
times green a right yellow a green a
then blue b
times green a
times blue b almost there i know this is
tds
times blue b
plus yellow a
intuition doesn't come easy though
yellow a
so we're on this term yellow a green b
blue b so green b
times blue b
now we're at
yellow b the good thing about the colors
it's easy to keep track of where we are
plus yellow b
times green a
times green a
times blue b
and then we're at the last one
plus
yellow b
yellow b
green b
green b
times blue b
times blue b
so this is the expansion of a plus b to
the third power right we haven't
simplified it at all but and i did that
for a reason because you see that every
term here
what what is what's happening here every
term has exactly
one um it's three numbers being
multiplied right every term is three
numbers being multiplied and it's one of
you know the yellow number comes from
the first from this yellow a plus b
the green number the middle number comes
from this middle a plus b and then the
blue number comes from this right hand a
b and you saw me i went all the way
through it right so hopefully you
believe this point
so so let's think about a couple of
different ways every term
essentially
we're essentially to generate each of
these terms in the expansion of a plus b
to the third we're picking either a or b
from you know for the from the yellow a
plus b we're picking either a or b right
we picked an a here we picked an a here
we picked a b here or b here and a here
and a here a b
and the group from the green a plus b
we're picking either an a or b
and then from the blue a plus b we're
picking either an a or b
right
so essentially the expansion if you
think about it
this expansion
we've essentially done
every every way
of choosing
three different things
right every way of picking either an a
or b from these three different terms
and that ends up with these what is this
one two three four five six seven eight
terms right
now let's make it a little bit uh let's
give you a little bit more intuition
square and i think as you're starting to
starting to realize why this is dealing
with permutations and combinations and
combinations in particular
once we simplify what happens this is a
to the cube right that's the only a
cubed term this is a squared b what are
the other a squared b terms
let's see a squared b this is also a
squared b so let me let me write down
all the a squared so let's see let's see
how many a squared b terms there are
i'll do it in a neutral color so this is
this is a squared b
this is b a squared but that's also a
squared b
what's another a square b this is also a
squared b right a times a times b
so there was three ways to get a squared
b and that's why you know when we
eventually write the expansion it's it's
going to we know that the coefficient in
front of it is 3
a squared b right of the the coefficient
on the a squared b term when we actually
multiply it out and we've done that
several times already when we we did the
binomial theorem especially we took to
the third power
so where did this 3 come from and why is
that the same thing as when we learned
the binomial
the definition of the binomial theorem
why is you know does it just happen to
be the case that that's the same thing
as
3
choose 2
times
a squared b
well no think of it this way
we already know that every term here
every term in the expansion
we're essentially picking either an a or
a b from each of these right we have to
pick one term from each of these
so the way you could think of it for a
squared b to get a squared b
we have to essentially say well how many
combinations and that's the key word how
many combinations are there where out of
these three
out of these three a plus b terms i am
choosing the a term i'm choosing two a
terms right because to to get a squared
i have to pick an a term twice
right and so that's where i have to pick
two a terms out of the three times i
pick so i'm picking three times two of
the times i'm picking an a term so
out of three times i'm choosing two and
that's where three choose two comes from
for the a squared b term
and so you could you know for the
a b squared term
you could say well i'm i'm picking an a
once how many ways are there way to
choose a
once when i'm taking from three things
so it could be three choose
three choose one
but that's also the same thing or it
should be equal to
you could also say well i'm picking how
many ways are there to pick b twice if
i'm picking three times well
if it's a b squared i'm picking b twice
so it's that should be equal to three
choose two a b squared and if you work
these out you will find that yes these
both turn out to be three and actually
that's why there's some symmetry there
um and and the combinations all work out
but but hopefully that's giving you an
intuition essentially when you when
you're doing the bind up so the binomial
expansion of this let me just rewrite it
again
it is
you know this is a plus b to the third
it's three choose zero of a cubed
b
to the zero plus three choose one of a
squared
b
to the one we could say plus
3 choose 2
of
a b squared plus
3 choose 3
of a
of a to the 0
b cubed
so what's this saying what's three
choose three saying
how many ways
if i'm taking if i'm choosing from three
different things how many ways can i
pick exactly three b's right that's how
you can view it how many ways can i pick
three b's i'm either picking an a or a b
right you could say it's either heads or
tails or you know red or black or white
but it's either a or b how many ways can
i choose
b three times from three things well
when you evaluate this you get this to
be one and that makes sense because it's
1b cubed and similarly i mean you could
view this
as how many ways
when i'm picking out of three things
can i pick exactly zero b's right that's
three choose beer how many ways can i
pick exactly zero b's well that's the
same thing as how many ways can i pick
exactly three a's this is also one
there's only one way to do it
and that's the way once again there's
only one way to do this one and this was
the way
there's three ways to get a squared b
there's three
there's three
combinations um
there's there's three possible actually
well unique permutations and but they're
all the same combination right so
there's three identical combinations for
picking two a's and a b and those are
this one
this one
and this one
so hopefully i didn't confuse you and
hopefully at minimum that gives you a a
glancing intuition of why combinations
are even involved in the binomial
theorem whether they're even involved
when you're expansion expanding a
binomial to some power
and at best i i really hope that i've
given you a deep intuition for why this
happens i will see you in the next video